تركيا يحاول فريق من 150 من رجال الإنقاذ
إنقاذ أمريكي محاصر داخل
ثالث أعمق كهف في البلاد. مارك ديكي
هو جزء من فريق بحث في
وادي موركا، وقد عانى من
نزيف في الجهاز الهضمي على بعد حوالي 1100
متر داخل الكهف،
ويقول اتحاد الكهوف التركي إن الوصول إليه
عملية معقدة.  قد يستغرق ذلك أيامًا،
أه سينيستر مانور كراتشر ينضم إلينا مباشرة
من لندن مع أحدث الأخبار، لذا فقط
اشرح المزيد حول كيف انتهى به الأمر
هناك في جامانا حسنًا، ماكس، ما زلنا لا
نملك الكثير من المعلومات حول كيفية
حدوث كل هذا ولكن ما لدينا  هل تفهم،
كما ذكرت من اتحاد الكهوف التركي،
أن مارك ديكي كان جزءًا
من فريق البحث المحلي والدولي الذي
كانوا فيه في هذا الكهف وهو
ثالث أعمق كهف في تركيا، ونحن
نفهم أنه في وقت سابق من هذا الأسبوع
من المحتمل أن نهاية الأسبوع الماضي لا تزال
غير واضحة بشأن ذلك  لقد أصيب بالمرض وكما
ذكرت فإن خدمة إنقاذ الكهف المجرية
المشاركة في هذه
العملية تقول إنه كان يعاني
من نزيف في الجهاز الهضمي وأنه
فقد الكثير من الدماء،
ويقول الاتحاد التركي إنه الآن
في حالة مستقرة وحالته
يواصل التحسن، ولم يعد
ينزف، وقد تلقى ما لا يقل عن ست وحدات
دم وهو قادر على المشي
بمفرده، ولكنه الآن في معسكر القاعدة
الذي لا يزال على بعد أكثر من ألف
متر من السطح وهي
عملية معقدة للغاية.  حاول إخراجه من
هناك لمحاولة إخراجه على نقالة
من هناك، لأن
ثالث أعمق كهف في تركيا، نتحدث أيضًا عنه كما
يقولون عن ممرات ضيقة جدًا ومتعرجة،
وهي عملية معقدة جدًا جدًا
والتي تتضمن الآن أكثر من 150 من رجال الإنقاذ
من  بلدان مختلفة في تركيا لديها
أه وكالة إدارة الطوارئ والكوارث الخاصة بها
وأعتقد أنها شاركت في هذا ولكن
لديك أيضًا رجال إنقاذ من دول
بما في ذلك الولايات المتحدة وكرواتيا والمجر وبولندا
والقائمة تطول والذين يحاولون
إخراجه من هناك، هذا
رجل  وفقًا لسيرته الذاتية، فهو
مستكشف ذو خبرة كبيرة، فقد كان يفعل ذلك
لعقود من الزمن منذ التسعينيات، وكان
يستكشف 20 ولاية أمريكية في 10
دول، وهو أيضًا مدرب إنقاذ
بنفسه، والآن سيتعين علينا أن ننتظر
ونرى ما سيحدث وفقًا لسيرته الذاتية
يقولون لاتحاد الكهوف التركي أن
هذا قد يستغرق أيامًا لأنه في
الظروف المثالية يستغرق حوالي 15 ساعة حتى
يصل أحد الكهوف ذوي الخبرة إلى السطح،
وهم الآن يتشاورون مع الأطباء
لمعرفة ما إذا كانوا سيتمكنون من وضعه
على  نقالة وأخرجه من هناك ماكس
بخير جامانا معك بأي
تحديثات شكرا لك أيها
الأجنبي